ce matin pour le groupe de retraités ces
séances de stretching postural les tapis
en place ils vont pouvoir adopter des
postures pour étirer leurs muscles
profonds et posturaux notamment ceux du
dos on met en place les positions comme
si vous mettiez des couches les unes
après les autres
toujours en respect de nos chaînes
musculaires au respect de nos
articulations
donc petit à petit on monte en puissance
atteint d'une maladie génétique qui
bloque les articulations
s'ils viennent bien depuis quelques
temps au cours de stretching
sur les conseils de son kinésithérapeute
c'est pas évident évident mais moi je
trouve que c'est enfin moi
personnellement je sais que ça me fait
du bien même si il y en a certains
posture je souffre un peu
un effort intense et bref qui s'adapte à
tous les âges pour préparer une
compétition de sport pour se détendre
pour soigner des maladies comme
dominique qui souffrent d'arthrose
mais qui vient essentiellement pour son
bien-être physique et morale
visuellement c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de se rendre compte de ce que
l'on peut ressentir de par la posture
parfois on a déjà un certain travail
ensuite à la mobilisation la durée qui
est quand même relativement courte on
est soutenu aussi par la petite
respiration qui est très spécifique à au
stretching postural un sport qui sert à
évacuer les tensions et retrouver une
harmonie corporels pour appréhender
l'année tout en douceur